hey everyone its Peter Brown reading for
Steve Watts Ori and the blind forest was
a delight in 2015 a tough-as-nails
combination of Metroidvania structure
and meatboy leg demands with a
surprising amount of heartfelt heft moon
studios follow up Ori in the will of the
wisps is every bit as graceful and
lovely as his predecessor even if some
of the emotional beats and exploration
feel a little less novel the second time
around
[Music]
all of the wisps picks up immediately
we're blind forest left off with orys
patchwork family unit welcoming a new
member the outlet coup the family is
happy and loving but who wants to fly
and Ori wants to help her soon the two
are swept off in a gale to a new forest
deep with rot which begins the adventure
in earnest the theme throughout the
story is the encroachment of the decay a
creeping evil that overtook the
neighboring forest after its own magical
tree wither but if it's meant to be ugly
you wouldn't know it from many of the
lush backgrounds especially in the case
of a vibrant underwater section in the
game War II is often swallowed up by
these sweeping environments emphasizing
just how small the little forest Spirit
is compared to their massive
surroundings
[Music]
Hori suite of acrobatic moves makes
delving into new areas a thrilling treat
exploration becomes especially engaging
as you unlock more abilities and become
increasingly adept some of them are
lifted directly from the first game
which can be disappointing next to the
excitement of discovering a shiny new
ability still those old standbys work
well and make the improvisational leaps
and bounds feel as great as ever the
picturesque vistas seem to be pushing
the hardware hard however playing on an
Xbox one X I encountered visual glitches
like screen freezes on a semi-regular
basis and the map would stutter usually
these were simple nuisance but once in a
while it would come mid leap and throw
off my sense of momentum and direction a
day one patch significantly reduces the
freezing and fix the map issue
altogether while Ori is ostensibly a
Metroidvania will of the wisps is less
focused on exploration and backtracking
than is typical for the genre your
objectives are usually clear straight
lines and shortcuts littered throughout
the environments get you back to the
main path quickly most of the Wanderlust
comes in the form of plentiful and
optional side-quests I was glad for the
freedom to pursue a critical path
without artificial barriers but I also
plan to go back and plumb the depths
simply to spend more time in the world
usually the reduced emphasis on
exploration seems to have been replaced
by a major expansion of combat rather
than the passing nuisance of the
occasional enemy all of the wisps
introduces myriad threats that are near
constant presence thankfully the combat
system has been overhauled to match the
elegance of the platforming the story
progresses forward with a sword and bow
with optional weapons for purchase the
combat does take some getting used to
though in part because it's built to
work in conjunction with orys nimble
moves well I felt awkward and imprecise
in combat at the start slashing my sword
wildly even at the mildest of monsters
my comfort level grew as I gained new
platforming skills around the mid game I
realized I had become adept at stringing
together platforming and combat skills
err dashing and bounding between threats
with poetic rhythm and barely touching
the ground until the screen had been
clear that level of finesse is necessary
because Orion will of the wisps
introduces a series of massive boss
battles each more complex than anything
in blind forest their attack patterns
are often signaled by barely perceptible
tells most of the time the boss fills up
a significant portion of the
interactable foreground and even more of
the background but this can make it
frustratingly difficult to tell what is
and isn't vulnerable to your attacks or
what parts will do crash damage this all
makes defeating them feel like a relief
in accomplishment
though sometimes more of the former than
the latter likewise tension-filled
escape sequences dot the map requiring
almost perfect precision and execution
of your toolset to survive a gauntlet of
threats the game offers occasional
checkpoints in these sections as well as
a more generous checkpointing feature
around the overworld the sprawling
bosses and climactic escapes are ways to
express a larger more operatic feel for
will of the wisps blind forest was a
humble little game that told an intimate
relatable fable whisps has a grander
scope and in the process it loses some
of that intimacy it still has moments
with emotional heft both exhilarating
and heartbreaking and Moon Studios still
has a way of expressing an incredible
degree of wordless emotion with subtle
moments of body language the story and
will of the wisps is often darker and
even as touching moments are more
bittersweet the chief antagonist an owl
named shriek is similar to the first
games Kuro and having suffered a tragedy
in the past but how that story addresses
that tragedy is significantly sadder and
stands as a moment of haunting animation
that will stay with me more than any
other single image from the game even
the moments of finality that end the
story while appropriately heroic and
hopeful are tinged with quiet sadness
and inevitability the sense that
everything ends that finality could
signal that this is the last Ori game a
farewell to a fantastical world and
memorable characters that made Moon
Studios such as standout developer from
its very first effort if that is the
case you can hardly ask for a better
send-off Rory and Will O the wisps is a
remarkable synthesis of artful design
and beautiful moments
[Music]